Oh God hey how's it going bros my name
is Pierre welcome back to D for this
game is awesome let's keep playing
yeah are we alone now no oh you went
away [ __ ] her tits are huge I realized
that I mean if everyone's okay hope no
one got hurt oh my god he's so creepy
stop that
rabbit the courier he vanished really he
was the guy that managed
okay find all the evidence eight pieces
okay let's look around nothing here what
do we got here
any evidence
nope but we're cleared out the AIA there
must be some evidence waiting back here
let's go
wasn't the other girl sitting in
business class anyway wife and Marshall
are you okay what's with the attitude
I'm only asking cuz I was worried you'd
think nothing happened at all that's why
it's been your jabber boy
Derek Buchanan I'm not sure why but he
seems determined to ignore me about his
wife about his bald head
you've got quite a young wife is there a
big age gap between you what the [ __ ]
y'all giving courage to men all across
our fair nation if a stonyface gorilla
like you can marry such a young
beautiful creature there's hope for all
of us ha ha ha ha ha ha but that's a
surprise you're the last person I'd
expect to be carrying a picture of your
family oh [ __ ]
listen up I don't know but if you want
to keep sucking down there okay that
seems fair enough let's not do that it's
not piss him off it's ok though a man is
far more than just his looks say someone
who's bald and ugly am i right
I'll show you cannon doesn't know who I
am
there's something very odd going on here
but just what is it no we yeah you know
what let's not provoke him in any
further all right
why are we sitting here why are we doing
this I okay
we did that great
nothing says Boston quite like this
uh-huh know that there must be a
baseball fan on board yeah no no we been
doing some baseball Aang really glad we
did that
oh this one's stuck there must be a
cleaver oh man I'm so glad I don't play
this on the [ __ ] Kinect that would be
a nightmare that's it all that effort
for oh it's the Boston versus New York
pretty good seats too of course it's
been used things don't come that easy
that a clue
this is seem like much of a clue what
why did we
okay apparently that was a clue of be
burger shows food locations okay this is
turn around then yeah there we go
apparently we need to [ __ ] eat right
now in here oh no come on it's food is
right there no oh my god it's hard to
find stuff and you find seven like Jesus
oh hello big titty alright alright what
are you doing that for
yeah perfect timing I can't take it
anymore
what hey what what is Debra talking
about lightning strike electrified the
floor and pan wheels
I need to try and calm it down talk to
the head what am I gonna do oh that's
cute
this is so weird
so sweet
lightning striking an airplane doesn't
shaking feel odd to you about the
squeaking window first
squeaking windows and now seats and
floors are electrified I'm almost
impressed by your capacity to worry
about the mundane hold it what was that
about the windows
nothing happened weekend right squeaking
the windows you're saying the windows on
this bucket squeak
what I got time 100 percent Cinco rate
okay okay so we got to see in her you're
pulling my leg if the windows were
really squeaking why we'd all be dead by
now that lightning strike would have
come in through the cracked window
we'd have smashed into the sea its
surface harder than concrete it's like
dr. Johnson always says fall from an
airplane and you'll die oh that's pretty
keep your fear mongering to yourself
this certainly doesn't seem to be an
accounting in the notes
what's going on here then okay so we got
a net a piece of evidence from talking
to Eric there's that mysterious [ __ ]
music again Jesus Christ oh my God he's
so creepy stop looking at me it's a
domestic flight no large bags well a
[ __ ] tuxedo I'll take it a spy
fiction yes keep looking god I hate him
Roland seems Roland as he sees you move
to this seat
women indeed oh my god yo mr. young okay
so funny you would ask what does that
mean if time changes so too does place
time is of the essence you of all people
should understand what does that mean my
god
cutlery has to be stainless don't you
agree
yes I do that lightning strike how did
you know about it
before it even happened don't tell me
you can control lightning strikes
ability to walk is not oh my god come on
great talk
what are we observing what am I looking
for what happened
oh dear control will be an issue if I
can't find it what
I'm pretty sure control is not the
problem oh my god where's Olivia excuse
me exactly which miss Olivia I'm
searching for Olivia Jones she's a
member of the crew just like you are I'm
very sorry sir but she isn't aboard this
flight come on
did that lightning strike you - she was
right here a moment ago okay we got it
in any case
he's still looking contact Logan Airport
immediately tell them we have an
emergency up here also get the BPD to
send some cops to the airport
detective Forrest Kayson in particular
give them my name and you'll have no
problems well excuse me sir
are you hoping to use this confusion for
something nefarious if so I'll have to
stop oh god no I'll break more than your
watch Oh God not that again no for
[ __ ] sake I can't
suspicious person immediately to our
destination Ronald Reagan International
Airport
now you'll excuse me I need to get back
to work
Jesus Christ jesus [ __ ] christ can we
get some food too here maybe so that was
a plus that was a clue okay I'll take
that clock set food I need food
is that a [ __ ] cat take that cat slap
that boat it oh my god is that we can
buy food of course that makes so much
sense why did I not think of this okay
let's keep investigating let's talk to
this guy you must have been sold
how is my Sookie Jesus Christ
there will be champagne as soon as we
arrive in DC think some Chardonnay my
didn't I didn't your mannequin just
break your right that's definitely
Sookie that mannequin totally says
Christ okay you win
forget I even asked about you miss oh my
god no more about Sookie that's right
she's not a mannequin we can forget this
ever happened
of course us being fashioned designers
I don't do autographs I'm here on my
private time let's ask about the
military maniac
when did you become a military maniac
this is a passion retro and military
it's called both Sookie and I are
completely anti war course okay but what
I really wanted to know was when did you
change your clothes progress cannot be
stopped when we change is not what is
important oh my god is nipples rather
the question should be when can we
change
just look the fashion we have on right
now is already headed toward obscurity
it's imminent new inspiration is going
to just explode into my brain oh my god
I can't have aunt
corn now I've been corn not retro but a
new style yes a new era no you got it oh
god what are we doing right now oh god
no oh god what have I done
that was a puzzle piece for for more
puzzle pieces
we definitely need something out of this
guy best game ever
we need a puzzle piece out of this guy
uh we got something the front does the
cherry blossom pattern they changed when
did that change over that's another clue
cool
three more okay it says ASD to look
around so maybe that's what we need to
do when we talk to him yeah that works
okay
what's that it did we find it the engine
isn't damaged yes apparently I do okay
we got it we never have to talk it to
him again I hope Jesus
[ __ ] hell two more pieces two more I
really feel like I don't know what at
where else to look honest me
oh yeah okay that's what we missed we
haven't been using this I didn't know
this changes everything
touch that ass yeah yeah high five dad
Buddha high 5 Buddha what do we got here
why am i bringing this up what am I
supposed to do with this thank you be
getting tired cuz I'm really out of
ideas the [ __ ] is happening
what Sims look like the real Sookie was
that another clue that was another clue
just that I've been struggling so hard
and it was so tight oh he has powder I
love butter okay that means we got all
the clues out of him
that means we just have one left where
is the last clue I swear to God right
there's a clue here are you kidding me
oh my god
I've looked so long oh okay
last clue for the love of God the Sun
wipe away the dirt I guess s there it s
wiping up the dirt beautiful sunset but
no it's me of the day I proposed oh my
god what is this I'm gonna [ __ ] go
insane by playing this game Jesus Christ
little Peggy I'll find who killed you
I will I found all the clues a prop it
probably just was a lot smoother for you
than it was for me because I edited it
out all the [ __ ] of me just going insane
I had collected all the puzzle pieces
what'd he say
this piece of the past has been solved
Marshall are you really sentimental
enough to hold on to a pen that can't
even write unexpected most unexpected
you seem quite different from the man I
first imagined you to be but that
doesn't mean you're totally free from
suspicion oh it's still the first time
for you oh [ __ ] to him the same pen the
Fenway Park ticket was a you thinking
uh-huh
what the seat cover pattern is cherry
blossom snow uh-huh
what are you rambling about I yeah the
destination is in the other direction
the Sun can be seen from the windows on
the right side in other words the
aircraft is flying south clean yourself
clearly I am David Young a private
detective who also collaborates with the
BPD now you Derek Buchanan I consider
you suspicious if you are the one I map
you're gonna remain heavily involved in
my investigation from now on so let me
give you this warning I'll do whatever
it takes to achieve my goal I'll never
give up even if it means I have to get
in your way so be ready for that oh one
other thing something I probably ought
to mention according to the BPD files
you get killed while transporting the
courier known as rabbit
what is gonna happen I don't know man
David yeah he's pissed going to be
killed apparently yeah no that's what he
said Tonio zapatero and Olivia Jones
they vanished
right in front of my eyes literally
vanished merrily they didn't vanish at
all no they were never on this flight
this isn't the AG flight 1 1 7 to Boston
it's a different aircraft heading for
Washington in other words they didn't
vanish I moved
must have happened at that moment I used
the broken fountain pen to come further
back in time
I don't feel anything from either one
anymore
David
why do you shave your beard everyday it
was just starting to grow out
little Peggy what should I do
did we just get zapped by the police
officer okay that was the conclusion of
episode 1 jesus [ __ ] christ if that
was episode 1 alright well if you made
it this far you got to stay with me
throughout this series this go be
amazing ok press that's all for me for
now I hope you enjoyed this episode
please leave a like to support your
series and I'll see you in the next one
as always stay awesome